you are watching ColdFusion TV
hi welcome to another ColdFusion video
to go guy here with innovations such as
hololens and the marriage of the pc and
mobile in Windows 10 it seems like
Microsoft is getting back on track after
some time being lost in the wilderness
for some fun let's take a look back at
some interesting facts and events in
microsoft's history that you may not
have known about number five the name
okay so let's start simple
where did the name Microsoft actually
come from Microsoft literally stands for
micro computer software a micro computer
was a term used to describe the early
personal computers in the mid 1970s
remember at this time computers were
still massive mainframes used in
corporate business the public didn't
even have the concept of what a personal
computer was in fact people in the
computing business even thought the idea
of a PC was ridiculous for example in
1977 Ken auslan founder of Digital
Equipment Corporation said there is no
reason why anyone would want a computer
in their home so in fact Bill Gates and
Paul Allen were way ahead of their time
to see the potential of micro computers
as early as they did in 1975 when they
started Microsoft number four the
Microsoft sound
there's a mysterious sound that would
bring most 90s kids back to their
childhood for a brief few seconds let me
play it
where did this sound come from the story
behind it is actually quite interesting
when Windows 95 was being developed
executives commissioned music legend
Brian Eno to develop a piece of music to
play when the operating system started
up the piece of music became known as
the Microsoft sound Brian Eno was chosen
because he had worked with the likes of
David Bowie and u2 I think I'm one of
the founding fathers of the recognition
that there are different ways of
listening to music but it's been around
for a long time there are other ways of
hearing music and other ways of using
music here are some quotes by brian
microsoft said we want a piece of music
that's inspiring universal optimistic
futuristic sentimental and emotional but
it has to be three point two five
seconds long I made 84 pieces I got
completely lost in this world of tiny
tiny little pieces of music I was so
sensitive to microseconds that when I'd
finished and went back to working on
four pieces of music three minutes
seemed like oceans of time unquote but
there's a twist to the story digging a
little bit deeper we find the pinnacle
of irony as it turns out and I actually
compose the music on a Mac but not just
this he's actually quoted as saying I've
never used a PC in my life I just don't
like them
number three Microsoft Bob Windows 95
was a smash hit and went on to become
one of the most iconic pieces of
software of the 20th century but
packaged with Windows 95
came a complete disaster called
Microsoft Bob Bob was an experiment by
Microsoft in user interface design it
was such a colossal failure that has
almost been wiped from history it
totally went against Microsoft's core
aspect of Windows 95 ease of use Bob was
supposed to be a cartoon-like interface
that skinned the whole operating system
instead of making the experience easier
users just got a slow clunky pile of
frustration instead
oh and one more thing earlier when I
said Bob had been wiped from history
that's not totally the case Bob did
actually leave something behind that's
right Bob gave the world Comic Sans
number two
Microsoft once saved Apple the year is
1997 Apple was in trouble with its
developers install base and investors
those absolute chaos in Apple's product
lines the company had almost run
themselves into the ground nearly
reelected CEO Steve Jobs said that the
company needed to strengthen its
relationship with Microsoft and one has
stood out as a relationship that hasn't
been going so well but had the potential
I think to be great for both companies
and I'd like to announce one of our
first partnerships today a very very
meaningful one and that is one with
Microsoft
Microsoft said that they would invest a
hundred and fifty million dollars in
Apple stock and continue Microsoft
Office support for the Mac and also help
with improvements and further
development this was largely seen as the
day microsoft saved apple but in truth
these two seemingly generous gifts to
Apple were part of a larger deal
although Microsoft did arguably save
Apple the 150 million dollars was
actually part of a lawsuit settlement
the discussions actually began because
there were some patent disputes and
rather than I know rather than repeating
history I'm extremely proud of both
companies that they have resolved these
differences in a very very professional
way number one
Microsoft has had a lot of experience
with smartwatches so as it turns out
Microsoft has already made a SmartWatch
11 years ago in 2004 it was called at
the Microsoft spot watch it was an
interesting idea it basically gave
useful information like sports news
weather and stocks over FM radio waves
but the rabbit-hole goes even deeper
before this the Microsoft Office team
worked with Timex to release arguably
the first SmartWatch in 1994 that's 21
years ago the Timex datalink was
developed as a wearable alternative to
mainstream PDAs it could also download
phone numbers from a computer the
interesting way is how it communicated
with the computer data was actually
transmitted using the light emitted by
the computers monitor the watch was to
work seamlessly with various elements of
office 95 and 98
so looking at this final fact in a
broader sense this brings us to an
interesting point on cold fusion we've
already seen how both smartphones and
smartwatches existed two decades ago but
never really kicked off the spark that
we're seeing today the same can also be
said for virtual reality it's almost
like we're living in a time where all
the conceived and imagined ideas of the
past and now finally feasible it truly
is great that we're the ones that are
able to witness this okay so that's
enough from me I hope you've enjoyed
these historical gems hidden within
Microsoft's past if there's any other
lesser-known Microsoft facts that you
happen to know feel free to comment if
you want to see more alternative videos
like this please subscribe to cold
fusion so you don't miss them thanks so
much for watching guys and I'll see you
again soon for the next video have a
good one cold fusion
it's rethinking